I've heard people say well we only had
anal sex so I'm still a virgin
[Music]
I'm Jessica Graham and I'm a sexual and
spiritual activist and author a sex and
intimacy guide for couples and
individuals and a meditation teacher I'm
Lance I'm a bartender by night and I
work in the entertainment industry by
day I'm Katie I worked in TV and film up
until two years ago I've been living the
mom and married life I'm grace I'm 25
years old and I'm a nanny in the day and
then a bartender at night I'm Kristina
I'm 34 and I'm an actor and also a youth
leader in ministry I'm Brandon I am 23
years old I work at social media
selective marketing
that is a true statement yes and I
clarify like I have not had sex in
general so I feel like that went with
the prompt cool just making sure you
know I grew up in the church and so I
was a typical like not gonna have sex
not gonna do a B through Z I just got
out of a two and a half year
relationship coming out of it I'm so
much more addict to how absolutely tough
that is on a day to day yeah I I did not
have sex prior to getting married almost
three years ago it made me test if this
wasn't a serious relationship going
somewhere then I could just focus on
kind of my other things Brenda I'm
curious um but the way in which you
engaged with your sexuality in your
two-and-a-half year relationship were
there things that you could do where
there are certain things you couldn't do
and is having an orgasm with somebody
considered not being abstinent
first of all to act like we didn't do
anything I'd be lying to you and act
like I'm just purify angel there's white
sheet is just a line and that's just
being upfront is I want to practice with
and is that okay I never want to
minimize sin and how I view that I never
want to run away from that sin is a very
heavy thing and unfortunately for a lot
of things we would be fighting and maybe
like getting doing physical things was
easier to either numb that or to make
that fight end you know like I'm so mad
at you right now I don't want to be mad
boom something happens physically right
and then we're like I guess we're cool
now and the whole orgasm sex thing right
like that's a thing I still wrestle with
I don't know I don't have a
black-and-white answer for you I still
dance in the gray area there but I know
that in my relationship it was used
sometimes as a beautiful thing or like
it was a natural thing of love and
passion and just being attracted to each
other but then there was also times
where it wasn't a lot of things we can
say sex is like I've heard people say
well we only had anal sex so I'm still a
virgin and to me that's like whoa
regular like just regular intercourse
you know before I did that so that's me
like you're more not a virgin than me
yes I have had sex outside of marriage
in a committed relationship did I want
to wait absolutely but love is a
powerful thing and when love comes in it
blinds a lot I wanted to say hey let's
just take this time and if we're gonna
get married let's just wait and we
weren't on the same page when it came to
that so when that relationship ended I
made a vow to God and myself to wait so
I do consider myself a born-again virgin
and I'll enjoy sex in marriage like ten
times more than I did outside of it I've
heard you know my whole life Oh sex
before marriage is a sin but then you
know murdering someone is always a sin
right but why is sex before marriage is
sin but after marriage it's not a sin
anymore
it's just because you have a piece of
paper saying oh we're married you know
now we can have sex I kind of agree with
you we make a big deal about it being
between God and that that's the whole
reason that you're abstaining so why why
does this people or some kind of
consensus being involved like make it
valid now they don't bring validity like
it still is between you and another
person thank God my first time was a
positive experience
my first time was with my first serious
girlfriend towards the end of high
school disorganized and messy and silly
at times but I look back on it really
fondly and we were losing our virginity
together which i think was a really nice
thing to share I lost my virginity in
like one of my first long-term
relationships also we were both virgins
which is good cause like neither of us
know what we were really doing so that
was it was awkward but it was it was
positive I mean I always went into it
thinking oh the first time I have sex
it's gonna hurt it's gonna be so bad my
heart's gonna feel so sad that I'm you
know I'm not married and stuff but I
felt none of that I was like this is
great yeah my first time was hilarious I
was almost 28 years old and of still a
virgin
on our wedding night so the honeymoon it
got a lot better you know argument used
so much against abstinence and celibacy
is that how do you know what you're
doing how do you like you're not gonna
be trained I think there's a cool part
of learning that process with each other
and learning that with one person and I
think that's just something that helps
you appreciate it love that person more
my first time having sex was not a
negative experience it just wasn't
necessarily a positive experience I was
14 and I just decided I had to do it I
had sex in the back of a hot rod car
with a guy who was I think about 18 the
way in which it was positive now when I
look back on it is that I started young
and I had a lot of colorful experiences
some of them positive some of them
negative but now I'm able to take all of
that experience and use it to help other
people sex can be just physical
great okay
I do think it can just be physical I've
had sex with people that I've I mean
they were cool but like I wasn't
interested in anything else other than
sex and then that was it
and you know they go on and I go on and
it was fine it's definitely for me
personally been something that has been
just physical at times both in and out
of committed relationships I think
that's a really important point to make
that that sometimes it can be used as a
a tool or you know or as just a way to
blow off steam after a hard day or
something that just doesn't require a
deeper connection
every time reiterate I almost always
prefer it when there is a deeper
connection it definitely enhances the
experience happen so I think that sex
can be physical from someone's own
thought process but I think you still do
you know that there's an emotional side
to it and so even sometimes I just have
friends that I know have said yeah this
is just sex for me too you know but
that's not truly how they feel a lot of
the time it doesn't mean something more
or they are hoping that it turns into
something more I definitely agree with
that but I would also say there's the
polyamory community there's the swinger
community there's the kink community
there's the just sex positive community
there's people who go to sex parties
every weekend and just have fun with
each other I think there are a lot of
communities that you just might not be a
part of where sex just for sex is
actually a very normal accepted and
positive thing then that's fine and well
but I do believe that when two people
are connected in an intimate way a soul
tie is connected and when you are about
to enter into another relationship or
enter into something new you're carrying
someone else with you it's like it's
like a web that's being weaved into
someone else
it's an emotional attachment but to some
people I do think that they can it can't
just be I guess I want and done thank
you next whatever but I do believe that
you're carrying a soul tie when you're
physically and sexually connected I've
been shamed for my sexual choices
yeah I've been shamed on both sides
because I grew up in the church too and
when I was not having sex I was shamed
by my friends that were and then once I
started having sex I was shamed by
people who were in the church who
weren't having sex yeah yeah it's crazy
on either side you I think you're just
gonna get shamed depending on kind of
people and the communities that are in
your life at that point in time there is
that aspect of it being shamed for not
doing it right and you know I work at a
place where I am one of very few
believers in my company people be like
you don't sleep with your girl come on
bro you know and I've had that in that
feeling of like that pressure of like am
I supposed to be like would that make it
easier what my relationship be better
and like and you start going to is it
worth the shame from the church is that
worth it like and you know that's and
that's a constant battle I always loved
sex and I had a lot of sex when I was a
teenager and I definitely had comments
like oh Jessica have sex with anyone and
that wasn't really the case but I
definitely got comments like that and it
never really bothered me I would I was
always just like huh screw you now in my
life I get a lot of different attitudes
just based on the way I put myself out
there but I do treat it as activism
because I think that by speaking out and
being willing to deal with the shame as
well as all the dick pics and
propositions I constantly get online I
mean it's part of I think of it as part
of the job you know but it's really
important and so I'm willing to have
people project their own shame just real
quick I want to say one thing I noticed
right off the bat being the only one on
the outside is that I'm certain that it
ties into my privilege I think in my
experience in terms of my parents and
things it's been more cautionary and
certainly from a caring loving place and
I haven't felt any shame sex ed
should encourage safe sex over
abstinence I want to run
yeah I'm gonna stay over abstinence yeah
uh-huh the reason why I chose to sit is
because although I'm Pro abstinence and
I'm celibate
education is education kids are gonna
make their own choices there's freewill
they're gonna act on impulse they're
gonna act on love they're gonna act on
whatever's present to them and if you
don't educate them on the safest way to
go about that how are they going to
learn I don't believe it should be over
abstinence but I do agree that it's a
big part of education for sure having
choice I think actually in some ways
works for the abstinence folks because
it's like if you don't if it's this bad
thing that you shouldn't do then of
course kids are gonna want to do it and
so I think like by just giving all the
information and offering choices then
you know people can make a choice yeah
so I think you guys addressed a lot and
I think when it comes with education
because knowledge is power we have to
teach kids why it is not don't do this
or God hates you it's not that it should
be we love God God sent His Son who gave
us the ultimate sacrifice and so we are
sacrificing a physical thing that we are
naturally drawn to I disagreed because I
think it you're painting just one side
of something that's really important you
know and it's the safety side but there
should also be if you feel like it's
meaningful to you you should definitely
wait until you're excited about doing
this and here's the safe way to do it
I still see an imbalance where and now
it's becoming taboo to talk about the
option of purity my desire is that we
don't allow on the next generation to
think that sex is completely meaningless
and has no emotion or feeling or reason
you know I think everyone has their own
journey waiting is not mine but you know
it could it's yours and that's awesome
so yeah just being accepting of
everyone's sexuality whether
be super high or non-existent at all and
just being open to listening to other
people's opinions all right that's a
wrap my god
[Music]
hey guys this is John thank you for
watching this episode of middle ground
we love this series and we love to hear
what you think about the episodes let us
know what you think in the comments
below and let us know what other topics
you would like to see in an episode of
middle ground and as always please be
sure to click Subscribe and check out
more of our videos